melvin et wii et wii
aïe aïe aïe je me déshabille tout de
suite non alors quoi vous devez dire du
mal de soeur emmanuelle a bien bien bien
alors je vois ravasi mais je vous
raconter une anecdote sur soeur
emmanuelle ou s'il est venu voir mon
spectacle en suisse il ya quelques mois
et je suis un sketch sur les sur les
juifs et j'explique que je suis plus
juif parce qu'on m'a retiré tous mes
points parce que j'ai fait noël isoc
et justement je faisais du une semaine
avant la mort etc
c'est dieu seul le sait et juste avant
de que de donner la réponse escient
emmanuel quitte au premier rang à genève
et qu'il y ait qui commença par les
réseaux les juges entendaient pas dans
ces deux espoirs et l'ogive masseur
bouge pas ce qu'on se tutoie son truc et
dont je cherchais le micro et 18 ans et
elle me dit à ma figure toi rien la
faille que moi aussi je suis juive
je crois qu'elle plaisantait sur ces
maladies qui étaient musulmanes ça me
fait marrer mais je suis français
ml oui je suis une fille une fille
dreyfus et je suis très fière d'être
juive soeur emmanuelle légiste donc j'ai
appris que sur un manuel était juste ce
soir là jean pierre foucault et oui jean
pierre foucault incroyable ya lustiger
aujourd'hui c'est jésus réécrit recrute
à l'extérieur
bien